[Music]
music is one of those things that just
reaches people and I feel like opera
kind of specifically has that effect on
everyone pure its raw and it's beautiful
I do feel like we're making it so
everyone can enjoy it
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Alexis Krieger and I'm an
opera singer a member of the opera
collective we're about 30 right now we
come together two to three times a week
to bring opera to the people we sing in
the subways of New York City my mom used
to always listen to the Met broadcasts
when I was fourteen she took me to the
met for the first time and queen of the
night came onstage and I saw her and I
said that's what I wanted to do most
people do have that initial feeling of
oh I don't like opera what is this opera
but bringing opera to the subway really
makes it for everyone and it really
makes it something that people feel like
they can connect with
[Music]
it's one of those places where people
just go by everyday all day long and so
you really get to see all walks of
people
[Music]
we've had people come and stand or sit
for practically the entire time were
there we had a note that was given to us
by a girl who was really not doing that
well that day she was sitting on one of
the benches and she was there for
probably close to two hours and at the
end of it she came up and put this note
along with some change into the bucket
[Music]
basically she had said that she had been
contemplating suicide and listening to
us sitting there and hearing that music
it just it changed her mind and that's
why we do this
I'm so happy that we can make that sort
of impact you know it's it's a really
beautiful thing walking down this quiet
street in Brooklyn you'd never know that
inside this building within this tiny
apartment the music is made
meet Evan and Luke there are longtime
friends and roommates Evan and I have
been living together here for how many
years have you lived the other man and
once a month in only about five hundred
square feet they managed to pile in up
to sixty musicians for the ultimate
recording session for each arrangement
we record it in about three hours and
post it online a lot of people's
reactions are that it seems crazy and it
is crazy to pull this off first they
have to uproot their humble abode
anything that is not involved in making
music has to go we take all the
furniture out
okay take most of the doors off it's
just all about making as much room as
much sightlines as possible
it really just looks like chaos there's
mic stands everywhere the floor is
littered with music Stanford I'm worried
about this though there's not a single
inch to spare and that's because they
make way for the strings woodwinds horns
percussion and a full choir yeah that's
a marimba in the kitchen
why I wanted an opportunity to record a
bunch of people at the same time Luke on
an opportunity to hear his Arrangements
played so we just invited a bunch of
people over and although it seems
unconventional there's a reason for the
madness we're trying to change the way
that you might see an orchestra play
there is a special dynamic and a feeling
in the room that you won't get in a
recording studio or in a public venue
[Music]
it's this unique sound and sense of
community that it's attractive musicians
from all over the country to participate
there's definitely something really
exciting about the idea that this
shouldn't really be possible it's a
really unique experience and I think
that people are drawn today and so they
keep at it
[Music]
it's a real kind of jarring wonderful
experience every time and we love it and
I bet the neighbors must love it too
they're lucky they're good nestled in
between the skin care love beauty spa
and Advani's pest control school here in
Elmhurst Queens is Indo Java a to IO
mini-mart for all things Indonesian but
every Tuesday it turns into the city's
smallest restaurant with truly authentic
Indonesian food you're in luck
you got the best table in the house it's
also the only table
[Music]
my name is cetera JIT I'm the owner of
the Indo Java we open in virtual five
ten years ago every Tuesday I could
write here for all the customer we call
Warren slasa so it's me
Tuesday food stop this little Superette
turned one table pop-up restaurant isn't
complete without one of the smallest
kitchens in the world our kitchen is
very tiny is a Love Kitchen because just
in a 40-person
two people might be a stretch it's half
the size of a broom closet but it
doesn't stop daily from whipping up
classic indonesian fairly good egg and
rendang i am before there is none
indonesian starved is difficult to find
the ingredient from indonesia and we
mistook community if we have a store the
indonesian people will come here and
then we still can't top indonesian
language that's our our dream and then
now this happened I am NOT a
professional chef I don't have any
education chef backgrounds so I just
learned from my mom in the last run the
chef always hide in the kitchen I like
to talk with the customer when I serve
the food so we can share in the story
they always say it likes me I have to
come again
[Music]
what do you call it with a cat let me
check on that
[Music]
it's called a clowder of cats
if you have a question any question
there's a number you can call 911
275 697 five and a librarian at the New
York Public Library will try to answer
it for you
hello thanks for calling ask NYPL we
have ten librarians on a team and we
answer any question that you may have
over the telephone in the office today
we have Matthew Barnard Sarina Diane and
me our department asked and ypl began in
1967 we started answering questions over
the telephone but people have been
reaching out to librarians for as long
as there have been libraries the New
York Public Library has actually saved
records of some of the more interesting
questions they've been asked over the
years like is there a full moon every
night in Acapulco why do 18th century
English paintings have so many squirrels
in them and how do they attain them so
they wouldn't bite the painter or Plato
Aristotle and Socrates one in the same
person in a world of Google it's a bit
surprising to know that they get around
30,000 calls per year my question is why
oftentimes people might not have access
to the technology at home and I honestly
think some just want somebody to talk to
so the next time you have a question
like how many teeth does a great white
shark have you can call this number nine
one seven two seven five six nine seven
five that will ring inside of this
building up on this floor and maybe
Barnard or Rosa will pick up and they'll
answer it for you
they have about 300 serrated teeth
[Music]
New York's a tough city to live in it
always has been the old saying if you
can make it here you can make it
anywhere I think because the birds have
made it here
I mean they've endured this far my name
is Steve Baldwin and I've been tracking
the wild parrots of Brooklyn for about
ten years now those two looks sort of
frisky it's not really that mating
season but my ups it of Monaco's
the monk parakeet native to argentina
and as far as we know something happened
at Kennedy Airport in 1967 or from 1968
it appears that a crate full of parrots
arrived from Argentina something went
wrong a bunch of them escaped they came
to Brooklyn College right here we've got
an incredible cast of parrots here today
one two three four they're smaller than
it's been a pigeon but larger than a
sparrow then the only kind of parrots
that build these freestanding structures
these nests can get up to the size of
small cars it's methodical work its twig
after twig after twig parrots are sort
of the primates in the bird world
they're smart they're communicative they
eat almost anything that's available to
them so they're perfectly set up really
to thrive in a place like Brooklyn even
though it's not where they came from
they've adapted extremely well you have
to I think have a certain fiber of Steel
that to make it in this town and I think
the parrots have those qualities
you
[Music]